What does Elektra bring to the
table that Captain America can't?
Is Victor von Doom really a better
villain than Ultron? We love the
MCU – we're not knocking it one bit – but the
old Marvel movies just did some things better.
There isn't a superhero film out there,
at least on the Marvel side of things,
that tells a more compelling and accurate
origin story than the original "Spider-Man."
Not only does it carry the heart of the
original Marvel comic books on its sleeve,
it combines the origin directly with
one of Spidey's most formidable foes.
Likewise, the 2005 "Fantastic Four" film, Ang
Lee's "Hulk," and "The Punisher," among others,
set their title characters up for success
early on. How is this done? By establishing
a clear origin story that often directly ties
our heroes to their most iconic villains.
While MCU films like "Iron Man" and "Captain
America: The First Avenger" stand out as solid
origin stories, most MCU films skip
their inception completely. Instead,
the films usually dive right into the action
to keep their audience's attention. That,
or characters are introduced in another
film before getting their own standalone,
which also often skip the origin stories. This
can be a huge disservice to both the characters
and the audience. Peter Parker watching his Uncle
Ben die, Bruce Banner's childhood flashbacks,
and Logan's frustrated attempts to uncover his own
history are what grounds and guides the heroes.
Plus, who doesn't love watching the Fantastic
Four as they get hit with cosmic rays from space?
"Rise and shine, big boy. How you feeling?"
There's no doubt that one of the things
we love most about movies like "Guardians
of the Galaxy" and "Thor: Ragnarok" is the
humor. The blend of character growth with
self-deprecating jokes is a true-blue staple
of the MCU, and for good reason — it works!
"I used to spin it really fast
and it would pull me off the…"
"Oh my God, the hammer pulled you off?"
"The ground."
In fact, many of us rewatch these films over again
just for the laughs. But the old Marvel films
took a different approach. While there are clear
moments of levity in "X-Men," "Spider-Man," and
"Daredevil," the films don't allow the humor to
hold them back from telling more refined stories.
Raimi's "Spider-Man" trilogy is the
perfect example of blending Spidey's
humor with compelling stories that
feel honest, raw, and genuinely human.
"I will… always be spiderman."
The "X-Men" series developed Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine in ways that no MCU character has,
simply by taking the character and his mythos
seriously rather than making a joke out of them.
The only reason an incredible film
like "Logan" could have even been made
is because of the groundwork they'd
laid with the character years prior.
There's a lot to be said about a complex,
interconnected universe where Howard the Duck
can chill with an immortal Elder and 20 years'
worth of Peter Parkers can meet up to make meta
jokes about their various movies' faults. It's
a whole lot of fun for fans, but it also means
you have to keep up with dozens of releases
to understand everything that's going on.
One thing the old Marvel movies really had going
for them was that they were truly stand-alone.
You didn't have to watch "Ghost Rider"
to understand a scene or two in "X-Men:
The Last Stand," and that's something of a
lost art nowadays. We've all gotten so used
to interconnected stories and universes
that we expect them now at every turn.
Aside from the "X-Men" and "Blade" films, which
really build off each previous installment,
most of the old Marvel flicks can be consumed
on their own. "Spider-Man 2" is just as great
if you haven't seen the first film as it is if you
have, and even "Elektra" isn't completely bound by
the "Daredevil" film she first appeared in. If
"Captain America: Civil War" proved anything,
it's that sometimes being too interconnected
can hurt the growth of your primary characters,
and that's not something the old Marvel
films had to worry about. Rather,
each made sure to focus on their own localized
story before expanding the world around them.
Since the foundation of the MCU, the franchise
has struggled primarily with their villains.
Aside from Loki, Thanos, Killmonger, Vulture,
and one or two baddies from the Netflix shows,
many MCU villains aren't terribly compelling,
interesting, or even believable. Most of them
don't stand out as anything other than pale
imitations of their heroes, and not in a good way.
The old Marvel films, however, understood their
villains completely. Our heroes' main foes were
dark, mirky reflections of themselves, and
not just because they had a similar Stark
Tech suit of armor. Rather, they made similar
choices to our heroes but with different results,
often warping their own perspectives of truth and
justice to fit their own agendas. The dichotomy
between characters like Spider-Man and Green
Goblin, Professor X and Magneto, and Reed Richards
and Victor von Doom is fascinating, powerful,
and full of surprises. In fact, some of these
villains are so iconic that they even brought a
bunch of them back for "Spider-Man: No Way Home."
"Attaboy."
The old Marvel movies also dealt with a completely
different set of philosophical implications
than most in the MCU. While "Iron Man" focuses
heavily on "War On Terror" politics and the
"Captain America" films reference PATRIOT Act
surveillance, earlier Marvel pictures went for
more universal, down-to-earth themes. They dove
into sociology, philosophy, and even religion.
Like the original Marvel Comics before them, the
"X-Men" trilogy ran underlying themes of equality,
hoping to remind us that people should
be treated the same whether they have a
difference in appearance or ability. This was
ultimately the message that Stan Lee hoped to
convey with their famed mutant characters,
and the Fox films handled it pretty well.
The "Spider-Man" trilogy heavily
promotes moral notions of responsibility,
which stand out among all superhero films
as being some of the most powerful ideas
explored in the genre. The "Daredevil" film
even touches on Matt Murdock's Catholicism and
how his role as Hell's Kitchen's "Guardian
Devil" is heavily influenced by his faith.
"Ghost Rider" explores the moral and spiritual
implications of selling one's soul. Likewise,
"Fantastic Four," much like the MCU's "Guardians
of the Galaxy" now, promotes the idea that you
can find your "true family" through friendships.
They weren't always the best films, but there's no
denying that the old Marvel films had a depth
to them that has yet to be fully replicated.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your
favorite Marvel movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.